aquí tenemos la gráfica de efe y también
tenemos cuatro expresiones distintas te
invito a que le pongas pausa al vídeo y
trates de determinar cuál de estas
expresiones va a dar el mayor valor el
segundo mayor valor el segundo menor
valor y el menor valor supongo que ya le
diste pausa y lo intentaste ahora
hagámoslo juntos en la primera expresión
estamos tomando la suma desde igual a 0
hasta 9 estamos tomando la suma de 10
objetos
el objeto cero el objeto 1 el objeto 2
así hasta llegar al objeto 9 estamos
sumando diez objetos empezando del 0
para empezar tomamos efe de menos 5 + 0
así es que empezamos ene efe de menos 50
la función f evaluada en menos 5 que
corresponde a esta altura que tenemos
aquí ésta es f de menos 5 es el valor
cuando y igual a 0
ahora cuando igual a 1 efe de menos
cinco más uno es igual a efe - 4
es la altura cuando igual a 1
continuamos con efe de 52 cuando y
igualados esta va a ser la altura
básicamente vamos a estar sumando los
valores de estas alturas desde efe de
menos 5 hasta efe de menos 59 hasta f de
4 y aquí podrías preguntarte cómo vamos
a relacionar todo esto con un valor de
área que de alguna manera es lo que nos
están pidiendo aquí que evaluemos como
establecemos esta relación pues lo que
tenemos aquí representado como los
términos de esta suma son valores de la
función en diversos puntos podríamos
decir que son estas alturas que tenemos
aquí quizás ya no estás t que aquí
podemos construir rectángulos cuya base
es igual a 1 de tal manera que si
multiplicamos la altura por la base el
valor del área va a ser igual al valor
de la altura aquí podemos poner que esto
está multiplicando a 1 ya resulta claro
que estamos multiplicando
altura por la base de este rectángulo y
luego de este rectángulo por lo que
básicamente estamos tomando rectángulos
e inscritos que podemos usar para
estimar para obtener una aproximación de
esta área que tenemos aquí en azul y
claramente nos va a dar un valor
subestimado pues no está considerando
estas áreas que tenemos aquí no está
tomando en cuenta esos valores de área
se ve claramente que los rectángulos
tocan o se encuentran por abajo de la
gráfica de la función déjame escribirlo
aquí este es un valor su estimado del
área de esta región sombreada en azul
veamos ahora qué representa esta es la
misma función
efe de menos 5 massey pero aquí la suma
empieza en igual a 1 y termina en igual
a 10 también aquí estamos tomando la
suma de 10 cosas pero veamos menos cinco
más uno es menos 4 efe - 4 es esta línea
que tenemos aquí por lo que ahora
aparentemente estamos tomando
rectángulos circunscritos pues aquí
también es como si estuviéramos
multiplicando por 1 al multiplicar por 1
estaríamos obteniendo el valor de esta
área obviamente al multiplicar por 1 no
se modifique el valor de esta expresión
así es que esa va a ser el área del
primer rectángulo circunscrito ahora
cuando y es igual a 2 va a ser
efe de menos 3 y ahora estaríamos
calculando el área de este rectángulo
déjame completar entonces el dibujo de
los rectángulos circunscritos que sería
algo como esto y como puedes ver ahora
estaríamos sobreestimando el área de la
región en azul
estos rectángulos circunscritos nos dan
una sobreestimación así hasta llegar a
igual a 10 donde tenemos efe de menos
510 f 5f de 5 es esta línea que tenemos
aquí la longitud de este segmento que al
multiplicar por 1 nos da el área de este
rectángulo y aquí podemos completar
todos estos rectángulos todos estos
rectángulos circunscritos que como ya
mencionamos al sumar las áreas de estos
rectángulos vamos a obtener una
sobreestimación pues estamos agregando
el área de estas pequeñas regiones que
tenemos aquí así es
expresión nos va a dar una sobre sobre
estimación ahora consideremos esta
tercera expresión vamos a empezar en y
igual a 1 y vamos a llegar hasta igual a
20 pero aquí la base de los rectángulos
no es 1 la base mide un medio de nueva
cuenta como la suma inicial en y igual a
1 vamos a hacer nuestra estimación
basándonos en rectángulos circunscritos
vamos a dibujarlos entonces lo voy a
hacer en un color que puedas distinguir
lo voy a hacer en naranja el primero lo
vamos a ubicar veamos en menos 5 más un
medio va a ser
efe de eso que es esta altura que
tenemos aquí la cual cuando la
multiplicamos por la base que es un
medio nos va a dar el área de este
rectángulo por lo que ahora tenemos el
doble el doble de rectángulos
circunscritos que se va a ver que se va
a ver más o menos así no los voy a
dibujar todos pues me tomaría mucho
tiempo pero son el doble de rectángulos
circunscritos también nos va a
proporcionar una sobra
y estimación pero va a ser menor a esta
que obtuvimos aquí pues en esta
estimación se consideraba además toda
esta región que tenemos en verde pero
con la nueva estimación el área que se
suma el área los rectángulos por arriba
de la gráfica de la función es menor es
decir es una mejor estimación aunque aún
el área bajo la curva se sigue sobre
estimando pues como vemos en este
intervalo donde la función está
creciendo los rectángulos circunscritos
sobre estiman el valor del área aunque
la estimación de la última expresión es
más precisa pues la base de los
rectángulos que estamos usando es menor
es de un medio así es que esta expresión
nos proporciona una sobreestimación que
es menor que la anterior y la última
expresión que corresponde a la integral
definida de menos 5 a 5 de fx de x y
como bien sabemos esto corresponde al
límite cuando tomamos rectángulos cuya
base tiende a ser cada vez más pequeña y
el número de rectángulos tiende a ser
cada vez más grande el número de
rectángulos tiende a infinito por lo que
el valor que nos proporciona la integral
corresponde al área real de la región
sombreada en azul
a real ahora sí quiero ordenar estos
valores de mayor a menor la mayor sobre
estimación se obtiene con esta expresión
esta corresponde a la mayor sobre
estimación esta también va a ser una
sobreestimación pero va a ser más
precisa pues está basada en más
rectángulos este es el área real a la
cual le corresponde el número 3 y esta
es una subestimación que le corresponde
el cuarto lugar esta expresión
proporciona el mayor valor mientras que
esta expresión proporciona el menor
valor